n
FrFredericton.
- - Merci.
C C'est officiel, le Collège ds
mémédecins retire les restrictis
susur la pilule abortive.
UnUne bonne nouvelle pour
dedes médecins qui demandaient
dedepuis longtemps la levée
dedes restrictions.
30300 médecins, des femmes pour
lala plupart, avaient même écrit
unune lettre ouverte la semaine
dedernière à ce sujet. La médecn
dede famille Dre Geneviève Bois
enen était l'instigatrice.
B Bonjour Mme Boir.
- - Bonjour.
- - C'est une bonne nouvelle;
vovos efforts ont porté fruit?
- - La nouvelle a été très bien
acaccueillie hier chez les
sisignataires à qui j'ai pu parr
dodonc une deuxième barrière qui
totombe après l'annonce par la
sesemaine dernière que le collèe
dede l'échographie ne serait pls
obobligatoire. On apprenait par
unune infolettre envoyer tous ls
mémédecins du Québec à la
foformation spécifique qui était
ununiquement une obligation dans
lala province du Québec ne serat
plplus une obligation. Donc, on
vivient de voir de grandes
babarrières augmenter le nombree
prprescripteurs pour la pilule
ababortive et l'accès à
l'l'avortement qui vient de tomr
ilil y a une semaine.
- - En quoi cette réglementation
llà était un frein pour obtenir
lala pilule abortive?
- - Il y a un frein logistique
popour un médecin qui ne sait ps
àà quel point il va offrir le
mémédicament de façon fréquente.
C'C'est laborieux de faire une
foformation personne obligatoire
popour pouvoir potentiellement
prprescrire la pilule abortive.
C'C'est pas toujours d'avance
ququand le soin de se redemande.
MaMais aussi d'un point de vue
plplus philosophique il n'y avat
papas de raison scientifique de
memettre à part avortement médil
dudu restant de la médecine. Por
lele restant de la médecine les
mémédecins sont les gens qui
dédécident les nombres de
foformation continue ils doivent
susuivre leur code de déontologe
enen maintenant une obligation
popour ce soin séparé de soins e
sasanté cinq contribuent pas à
enencourager les gens à
s's'impliquer à prescrire l'appl
ababortive ni rendre l'avortemet
momoins tabou.
- - Le collège annonce également
ququ'il veut se pencher alors
ququ'il a un groupe de travails
ququi va se pencher sur l'apport
popossible d'autres professionns
papar rapport à la pilule
ababortive. Est-ce que vous croz
quque par exemple les infirmièrs
dedes pharmaciens devraient
popouvoir la prescrire?
- - Ce qu'on voit dans le resteu
CaCanada ce qu'il y a des sages-
fefemmes ou des infirmières
prpraticiennes qui offrent parfs
dedes soins de santé reproductie
cocomme l'avortement médical. Is
n'n'y a pas de questions se sont
imimpossibles Québec. J'espère e
c'c'est une voie qui serait
exexplorée c'est quelque chose i
dodoit être discuté avec les
orordres professionnels concerns
ququi ne sont pas régis par le
cocollège des médecins. Donc ele
popourrait commencer à prescrire
sasans nécessairement l'aval du
cocollège mais c'est mieux si on
trtravaille ensemble. Donc consl
popourrait aussi augmenter l'acs
dede plusieurs façons. Allez vor
unun praticien qu'on connaît déà
ququ'est notre infirmière, notre
sasage-femme ou notre médecin pt
aiaider au lien de confiance. Ça
popourrait être une belle avenu.
JeJe ne sais pas encore qui sera
susur le comité ce qu'il sera ft
susur le comité. Ce sera à voir
cocomment ça se déroule ces
trtravaux-là. Mais c'est certain
ququ'il faut essayer d'augmenter
l'l'accès aux deux méthodes
d'd'avortement donc réduire les
emembûches qui sont en ce moment
susur le chemin des personnes qi
asassurent l'avortement.
- - Cette décision du collège ds
mémédecins a été un peu précipie
ouou la règle flexion a été
acaccélérée en raison de la cour
susuprême des États-Unis qui vot
jujustement restreindre le droià
l'l'avortement pour de nombreuss
AmAméricaines. Quels sont les
babarrières encore à l'avortemet
auau Québec?
- - Il existe de nombreuses
babarrières à l'avortement Québ.
IlIl y a trois grandes catégoris
: : logistique donc ce n'est pas
paparce qu'on a beaucoup : serve
ququalité en un qui peut nous
dodonner des rendez-vous dans un
momoment raiaisonnable proche de
chchez soi. Il y a un enjeu en
tetermes d'accessibilité souvent
leles rendez-vous peuvent prende
1,1,2 semaines ou même plus dans
leles grandes villes. C'est
ququelque chose sur lequel vous
trtravaillez. L'aspect financie.
LeLes femmes qui n'ont pas
d'd'assurance valident doivent
papayer et ensuite se faire
rerembourser si elles ont notre
asassurance. Mais si ce sont une
asassurance privée ce ne sera ps
papayé ou les gens qui n'ont pas
lala RAMQ. Il y a aussi l'enjeu
d'd'information. Il y a plusieus
cecentres anti choix sont des
cecentres de crise qui donne de
l'l'information erronée sur
l'l'avortement qui tente de
dédécourager les personnes de
coconsidérer cette option et c't
trtrès grave.
- - C'est vrai